Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai une question
de Dominique, qui me
demande :
« Les musées devraient-ils redonner
tous les objets autochtones
qui appartiennent à des communautés
encore existantes, et comment? »
Dominique, ta question est excellente,
mais elle a un historique très long
qui serait difficile de rentrer
dedans au complet,
mais, ce que je vais expliquer, c'est qu'il y
a eu une très grande problématique avec les musées
et des fois l'acquisition que les musées
font des objets autochtones.
Il y a des cas extrêmes, comme je pense à un
missionnaire aux États-Unis qui a créé
un espèce de mini musée dans son sous-sol.
Mais il l'a rempli en allant chercher
des objets des fois de manière
extrêmement illégales, comme en allant
dans les tombeaux de personnes
autochtones et en ramenant
les objets illégalement au pays,
aux États-Unis. Mais ce n'est pas
une pratique qui est qui est ignorée
des musées. Parce que beaucoup d'objets
dans les musées ont été des fois acquis
de façon non respectueuse
des communautés autochtones.
Alors, je pense des fois à certains
mâts totémiques qui ont été volés
dans l'Ouest en plein milieu de la nuit par
des explorateurs. Certains objets, aussi,
qui sont très difficiles à exposer
parce qu'on va parler d'ossements de personnes
qui ont été dans le fond ramenés
dans des pays européens ou même
dans des musées canadiens ou américains.
Et ce sont quand même les restes
de tes ancêtres, de ta culture.
Imagine si on allait chercher ta grand-mère
et qu'on décidait de l'exposer au musée
pour des raisons culturelles ou sociales.
C'est très difficile d'expliquer ça.
C'est encore le principe même de dire
est-ce qu'une momie, c'est assez vieux pour dire
qu'il n'y a plus de lien familial?
Ça, ce sont des questions que chaque nation
a le droit de répondre à sa manière.
Cependant, il y a eu beaucoup de travail
qui a été fait par les musées, surtout quand
on pense aux recommandations par rapport
à la Commission de vérité et réconciliation
de travailler avec les communautés.
Donc c'est certain que certaines
communautés voudraient avoir
certains des objets restitués
parce que ce sont des objets sacrés
ou des objets qui peuvent être utilisés
dans les cérémonies. Mais des fois,
c'est difficile aussi d'avoir
un lieu pour les protéger,
pour les garder, les restaurer.
Donc c'est important d'avoir des ententes,
aussi, avec les musées pour
que certains objets restent dans les musées,
conservent leur statut d'objet muséal,
mais puissent être sortis dans des occasions
spéciales par les communautés pour faire
des cérémonies.
Et justement, cet échange-là permet
un équilibre entre pratiques muséales
respectueuses et accessibilité à nos
objets ancestraux. Mais c'est certain
que c'est du cas par cas dans chaque musée.
On parle même d'universités qui ont des objets
ou des restants d'êtres humains
encore dans leurs collections
et qui ont de la difficulté à les laisser aller
parce qu'ils voient l'objet muséal
et nous, on voit l'objet culturel
qui a été volé. Donc c'est certain qu'il faut
qu'un processus s'engage entre
les communautés et les musées qui ont
certains des objets pour pouvoir donner
de l'accessibilité et pour pouvoir faire
en même temps de l'éducation pour
nos jeunes, pour qu'ils puissent voir
les objets qui font partie de leur culture.
Parce qu'il y a des objets un peu partout
qu'on ne voit plus puisqu'ils ont
été mis dans des musées. Alors, Dominique,
merci beaucoup pour la question.
J'espère que ça va vous intéresser sur
l'enjeu de la protection des objets
ancestraux et des pratiques muséales et
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des questions.
N'hésitez pas à partager le vidéo.
Je vous souhaite une très belle semaine.